this week's 48 hours is taking a new
look at the kidnapping of 26 children in
California in 1976 a story that gained
International attention three men
hijacked a school bus and then buried
the children alive along with their bus
driver all of the kidnappers have since
been released on parole this morning
we're sharing the story of one of the
survivors who gave an interview that has
never been seen before lead National
correspondent and 48 Hours contributor
David begno has more
it was the summer of 1976 when this bus
pulled into the small town of Chowchilla
California inside were 26 traumatized
children outside were their frantic
parents
these children had been through an
unimaginable ordeal kidnapped and buried
alive inside an old moving truck beneath
a rock quarry
ten-year-old Jody Heffington was one of
those kids
they just let us off the bus with all
these people
who were your parents were
[Music]
police immediately zeroed in on 24 year
old Fred Woods the son of the owner of
the rock quarry and two of his friends
James and Richard schoenfeld Jill
klingey was an assistant district
attorney for Alameda County this crime
was planned out for a year and a half in
intricate detail you actually have a
document
labeled plan and it sets out the way
they were going to commit the kidnapping
with the overwhelming evidence against
them the three men were arrested
convicted and eventually sentenced to
life with the possibility of parole
they're young they're wealthy I think it
added a component of Fascination to the
story because it was so unlikely that
three men such as these would commit
such a atrocious crime despite Jody
testifying at some of the kidnappers
parole hearings they were eventually
paroled and released
she has spent a lifetime trying to find
some peace of mind it just took
something from me that I can't ever get
back
and I can't tear it down
no matter how hard I try and no matter
what I do
David begno joins us now from Los
Angeles good morning David how are you
good morning good to see you Adriana
so we're sorry to say that Jody
Heffington died in 2021. David why is 48
Hours sharing this interview with her
now
well so Jody spoke to a producer of ours
at 48 Hours years ago but for security
reasons we were never able to air that
interview she passed away in 2021 as you
said and it was her son's wish for her
voice to be heard so this is one of the
few in-depth interviews that Jody ever
did and so we're really happy that the
world's now going to be able to finally
hear Jody in her own words tell her
story
David we heard about the possibility of
parole one of those kidnappers of Fred
Woods got parole last year do we know
why
so Tony since Woods committed the crime
when he was young he falls into a
California law that requires parole
Commissioners to actually give weight to
freeing inmates who were convicted in
their youth but are now elderly and have
served long prison sentences since Fred
Woods was 70 years old when he was
released from prison
David the kidnappers came from wealthy
families why would they commit this
crime for ransom
so years after the kidnapping James
schoenfeld said that despite their
parents wealth Nate he and Fred Woods
were actually in some pretty serious
debt he explained quote we needed
multiple victims to get multiple
millions and we use children because
children are precious
David thank you so much you can see
David's report remembering that
Chowchilla kidnapping on 48 hours
tomorrow night at 10 9 Central right
here on CBS and on Paramount Plus